good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Akhil amar I'm a sterling
professor of law and political science
here at Yale I'm filling in for Ian
Shapiro who is in a plane somewhere and
sends you all his greetings and and he
would like you to feel most welcome here
at the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale University
it's my great pleasure in Ian's stead
and honor to introduce our very
distinguished since Henry Stimson
lecture professor Vernon Bob Danner and
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
him now and he asked me not to be too
effusive but I'm supposed to tell you
some things and then I'm actually gonna
go off script and say some more things
that I'm sure will embarrass and even
further so he is a professor a professor
of government at the Institute of
Contemporary British history King's
College in London a frequent contributor
to TV radio press a fellow of the
British Academy honorary fellow of the
Institute for Advanced Legal Studies and
fellow of the Royal Historical Society
of the Academy of the social sciences
he's been an advisor to any number of
governments including those of and this
is I think in alphabetical order
the Czech Republic Hungary Kosovo Israel
Mauritius Slovakia and Trinidad in 2008
he was awarded the sir Isaiah Berlin
award by the political science political
Studies Association for lifetime
contribution to political science in
2009 he was made a Chevalier the Legion
d'Honneur by President Nicolas Sarkozy
his books include devolution and more
recently one of the books I especially
wants to bring to your attention beyond
a grexit toward his British constitution
that's for 2018
now the overarching title of his
lectures this week and next is britain
and europe in a troubled world they'll
focus on four themes today reserve but
proud reserve britain's detachment from
europe on wednesday Pandora's box and
the Trojan horses Britain in Europe next
Monday brexit means brexit written out
of Europe that's April 15th which us
which we Americans know us tax day and
the last lecture never closer Union does
the EU have a future that's Wednesday
April 17th I hope you'll join us for all
of them the funding for this lecture
series comes from an anonymous donor in
honor of Henry Stimson Yale College 1918
88 excuse me attorney and statesman
whose government service culminated with
his tenure as Secretary of State during
World War two since 1998 the Macmillan
Center and the Yale University Press
have collaborated to bring distinguished
diplomats and foreign policy experts to
the Senate to lecture on their books
that are then published by Yale Press
recent Stimpson lectures have included
talks by John Donne I think that's the
Michael Walzer anyway Michael David make
you our own beloved date David made you
Susan's end from Williams and many
others so now I'm going to go off script
a little bit and just speak a little bit
more person that's what Ian wanted me to
say and I wanted to just say just a
couple of words more about what an honor
it is to welcome our distinguished
lecture in my capacity as a
constitutionalist and a Singapore now
some of you know I get to teach
constitutional law here at Yale it's
really an extraordinary opportunity it
sure beats working but our Constitution
and revolves in America very tightly
around a small test and those of us who
study it we might be commenters about it
and that's that's about it now the
British constitution of which our guest
of honor is an expert is does not
consist of one clarified short document
but a whole cluster of important texts
Magna Carta active union principles
institutions practices and centrally
works of authority pieces written about
these central elements trying to
synthesize them into a coherent whole so
so our guest today is actually in some
sense that no living American is a
framer a family's not merely an
interpretive the project because some of
his works are in a tradition going from
stretching back to Blackstone Walter
Paget
a dicey his works have already become
and will continue to be works of
authority will be telling us what that a
part of this unwritten British
constitution so just right over here we
have a residential college named for Ben
Franklin you see and he was a great
founder but he's no more we can't talk
to him we can't talk to Lincoln the
constitutional amendments that have
happened in our lifetime are not
particularly momentous we have with us
here really a founder in an important
way the modern British constitution the
world so here's what's really we bring
lots of very distinguished people yeah
that's what Yale is we bring people who
are extraordinary for us thinkers and
our guest is surely that you've heard
his resume and sometimes we bring people
feel or extraordinary as doers Mike the
great Henry Stimson for whom this series
is its name only very rarely though do
you have someone who is extraordinary
and a dude and even then it's it's not
obvious the case that what makes them so
famous as a favorite is also what makes
them so extraordinary as a doer Benjamin
Franklin was a framer but actually I'm
not sure he was the best constitutional
figure of Disney alright he's maybe I
need to speak up he's famous for other
things like the lightning rod and
bifocals so so but our guest of honor is
actually a thinker and a doer on the
same topic and more and more what he
thinks about and what he writes about is
perhaps one of the most important issues
in our world today
the relationship between britain and
europe so it's as if we have in our mist
Ben Franklin talking to us at the moment
let's say of the impounding of the
American Constitution about his ideas
about constitutionalism that's actually
in effect what we lack today so it gives
me a really an extraordinary pleasure to
introduce our guest of honor well our
kill thank you for that generous
introduction and you've really
embarrassed me more than I thought
possible and were very kind to call me a
constitutional expert but you may say
that it's not difficult to be that if
you come from a country which doesn't
have a constitution and when I was a
professor of government at Oxford my
colleagues rather unkindly said that a
constitutional expert was just a
historian who'd given his telephone
number to the journalists now I must say
I think it was extraordinarily
farsighted of Yale to ask me to give
these lectures and a week when
extraordinary and striking things are
happening in Britain as you may know the
date in legislation for us to leave the
European Union is this Friday at
midnight continental time 11:00 p.m.
British time you see even on that
there's a divergence between Britain and
the continent and it's very possible
that in the next two or three weeks we
will have a change of prime minister
indeed I would say probably more likely
than not but that's just a guess but any
rate that our prime minister Theresa May
has said she will leave shortly and she
shall be the sixth of the last seven
conservative prime ministers who's been
ruined by Europe the question of our
engagement with your
from the time that Harold Macmillan
first applied to join the European
communities in 1961 and I'll be talking
more about that in future lectures but
might be of interest to point out two
resumes six of the last seven
conservative prime ministers be ruined
by Europe the one exception was Alec
douglas-home whose only Prime Minister
for a year so he didn't have time to be
ruined by Europe
I hope these lectures cast light not on
this just this topic but also on much
more fundamental problems of modern
politics the grand themes of nationalism
and internationalism sovereignty and
identity and perhaps most fundamental of
all the question of whether a nation can
or should escape from its history which
is a problem of particular significance
to a country such as Britain with its
long evolutionary and on the whole
peaceful history perhaps it's worth
pointing out the British monarchy can
trace its origins back to the 7th
century and Parliament has its origins
in medieval times and the question
perhaps worth asking is whether that
history remains an inspiration or is it
instead a constraint
preventing Britain from adjusting
effectively coming to terms with the
modern world and I think the working out
of these themes is important to
Americans as it is to us in Europe and
Henry Stimson was of course himself
concerned as Franklin Roosevelt
Secretary of War with the postwar
reconstruction of Europe though the main
problems he faced were connected with
Asia but he was most definitely an
internationalist and during his lifetime
it was absolutely clear that America
could not but be concerned with what was
happening in Europe
now perhaps Europe first impinge upon
America at the beginning of the 20th
century
in 1911 there was a crisis between the
European powers that could have led to
war when Germany is sought to contest
French clay
to a sphere interest in Morocco which
was to become a French protectorate in
1912 and Britain at that time had an arm
taunt with France and supported France
in the diplomatic dispute which ended
peacefully but after the Christ's had
been resolved America's former President
Theodore Roosevelt incidentally once
American student of mine once told me
that the Republican Roosevelt's
pronounced their surname Roosevelt while
the Democratic branch of the family
pronounced their surname Roosevelt I've
never heard that confirmed or we need
refuted by anyone I want if anyone can
tell me were that's right or not I'd be
grateful anyway Theodore Roosevelt told
the German ambassador that if Germany
had overrun France the United States
would not have remained neutral and the
Ambassador said this seemed contrary to
the Monroe Doctrine and Roosevelt
replied in the following way he said as
long as England succeeds in keeping up
the balance of power in Europe not only
in principle but in reality well and
good should she however for some reason
or rather fail in doing so the United
States would be obliged to step in at
least temporarily in order to
re-establish the balance of power in
Europe never mind against which country
and he then added in fact we are
becoming owing to our strength and
geographical position more and more the
balance of power on the whole globe and
that is an astonishing prediction of the
course of 20th century history because
of course twice in the twentieth century
Americans felt they were compelled as
Theodore Roosevelt had said to step in
to protect the balance of power in
Europe and resist German attempts to
become the dominant power on the
continent and twice in both world wars
if if it had been confined to European
powers Germany might well have won and
the key factors in both wars were the
intervention of America and of the
Eurasian landmass of Russia
was only partly a European power so if
any American were to ask why they should
be interested in what happens in Europe
you can point to the world wars most
Americans might have thought in 1914
that an obscure Balkan quarrel involving
the assassination of the heir to the
Austrian throne in in Sarajevo had no
relevance to them or that a quarrel
between Germany and Poland in 1939 about
the city of Danzig had no relevance to
them but they would have been wrong at
the end of the First World War the
American President Woodrow Wilson made a
speech in Colorado I think his last
speech before he had a stroke and he
spoke of Americans who had sacrificed
their lives to create a better Europe
and a better world he spoke and I quote
of the serried ranks of those boys in
khaki not only those boys who came home
but those dear ghosts that still deploy
upon the fields of France and he spoke
of his clients as the next generation
and said he intended to redeem his
pledges they shall not be sent upon a
similar errand though of course they
were now in 1966 when Frances president
de Gaulle sought a more independent
stance in relation to NATO
he asked the United States to remove her
men and bases from French territory an
American President Lyndon Johnson asked
whether the American cemeteries
containing the graves of some 60,000
American soldiers should be removed as
well now a main motivation behind the
construction of the European Union was
the desire to prevent future Wars by
overcoming the forces of nationalism
which had caused them the European Union
was and remains essentially a peace
project and you can divide the history
of Europe since 1914 into two neatly
contrasting periods between the wars
polity
on the continent was marked by
turbulence and stress but for nearly 75
years its western half has known
political stability and high rates of
economic growth and this is in do part
due to the recognition of collective
security and interdependence in a
continent which had suffered badly from
the absence of it now the book from
which I quoted Theodore Roosevelt's
comment on the balance of power has as
its title the last European war and that
is a description the author gives to the
second world war since it seems to be
the last war fought to prevent one
European power from dominating another
and since the end of the Cold War it is
highly unlikely that a purely European
power were ever again seek to dominate
the continent and of course no European
power can hope to aspire to match the
United States a superpower but Hitler's
attempt to dominate Europe nearly
succeeded had it succeeded there would
have been a united Europe but it would
not have been United in freedom and when
in 1940 the British government decided
to continue the fight against Hitler
against seemingly impossible odds
Winston Churchill said that Britain was
fighting by ourselves alone but not for
ourselves alone his aim was to liberate
Europe and once that had been achieved
European leaders had to decide how such
future catastrophes could be avoided and
they came to the view that Nazism and
fascism were bat extreme examples of
nationalism and that Europe would not
know peace until nationalism had been
transcended now at the beginning of the
20th century the force of nationalism
had appeared to be an essential
ingredient of self-government and
therefore of democracy the ideal of
self-determination within national
states was founded on the 19th century
liberal view that humanity was naturally
divided into nations and that every
nation should have its own state it was
a doctrine champion with great
enthusiasm
American President Woodrow Wilson and in
Europe the 20th century ideal of
self-determination was perhaps best
symbolized by Joseph Pilsudski the
Polish leader between the wars who tried
though without success to create a
multinational Polish state in which not
only polls but minorities Jews
Ukrainians Lithuanians and Germans would
feel comfortable Pilsudski had began as
a socialist but when he led the movement
for Polish independence his former
socialist comrades reproached him and he
rejected them
with the following words he said
comrades I rode on the red painted tram
car of socialism as far as the stop
called
independence but there I alighted and he
then added you are free to drive on to
the terminus if you can but please
address me as sir now what pilsudski
said in a way symbolizes the 20th
century because in the 19th century Karl
Marx had predicted a future based on
class war and revolution but in the 20th
century the classes collaborated and
wars were fought in Europe between
multinational empires and independent
nation-states and after the fall of
communism at the end of the 20th century
popular nationalism long suppressed by
communism broke up the Russian Empire
created by the czars and extended by
Stalin as well as the two multinational
states created in 1919 by the treaties
ending the first world war
Czechoslovakia and Yugoslavia and the
legacy of Woodrow Wilson's idea of
self-determination was shown to have
outlasted that of Lenin in the 19th
century most liberals welcomed the
advance of nationalism which they
associated with government by consent
for consent so it seems was most easily
confirmed within a national community
the Italian liberal recepy mad scene
they saw nationalism as an analogue on
the political
level to individual freedom Matheny
hoped to see a Europe of independent
nation-states
freely cooperating together for the good
of their peoples individual and
collective self-determination was seen
not only as compatible but indeed
complementary and it was for this reason
that liberals supported nationalism
against its enemies whether those
enemies were clerical reactionary or
monarchic Oh
in Britain it was a struggle for Italian
unity and self-determination the
Risorgimento which persuaded Gladstone
to switch from the Conservatives of
Liberal Party in November 1914 another
Liberal prime minister Asquith declared
that one of Britain's war aims was to
ensure that the rights of the smaller
nationalities of Europe are placed upon
an unassailable foundation he was of
course thinking of Serbia and Belgium
but those sensitive to our own native
British hypocrisy might bear this in
mind but when at the end of the war one
particular small nationality on
Britain's own doorstep the Irish sought
to secure these very same rights by
voting for the separatist shin famed
party in 1918 which refused to recognise
Westminster and set up a separate
Parliament in Dublin the response of the
British government far from ensuring
that these rights were in Asquith words
placed upon an unassailable foundation
the response of the British government
was to refused to recognise the Dublin
Parliament's and attempt to put down
Sinn féin by force
so we perhaps like other countries have
our own hypocrisy now men such as
Gladstone on a squid could not foresee
that the generous impulses behind the
Risorgimento would lead in Italy to a
fascist regime led by Mussolini who was
to prove the model for Hitler and
perhaps and fascism and national
socialism behind all their rhetorical
rhodomont odd were really nothing more
than labels for radical nationalism
carried to extreme lengths and the 20th
century has been inhospitable to the
hopes of liberal nationalists
such as martini and by contrast were
their nineteenth-century predecessors
liberals today tend to see nationalism
as an enemy rather than a friend this
was predicted by Woodrow Wilson
Secretary of State Robert Lansing who
declared with some prescence that the
phrase self-determination was loaded
with dynamite it will raise hopes that
can never be realized it will I fear
cost thousands of lives in the end it is
bound to be discredited to be called a
dream of an idealist and of course the
principle of self-determination was to
be used by Hitler to justify the
annexation of Austria and the
german-speaking heirs of sudha of
Czechoslovakia in 1938 so while the aim
of 19th century liberals was to give
effect to nationalism their successes in
the latter half of a 20th century have
sought to transcend it and the movement
to unite Europe after 1945 was an
attempt to transcend that force which it
was believed had been responsible for
the ruinous wars that had ravaged the
continent it was an attempt to replace
an international system by means of
which sovereign states somehow adjusted
their claims against each other as they
arose so as to preserve a balance of
power to replace that with a system in
which they could be adjusted within a
single framework that of European unity
as it were to internalise conflict so
rendering it peaceful and it also had a
geopolitical significance because
Europeans had come to realize their
weakness in the face of the superpowers
and they did not want to become totally
subordinated to the United States they
wanted decisions affecting Europe to be
made by Europeans the only way if that
dependence could be avoided would be if
Europe were to unite so the idea of
European unity stemmed from a sense of
the continents weakness not its strength
the danger that the destinies of Europe
would depend not on her own efforts but
upon the disposition of powers outside
Europe now Europe had not been united
since the end of the Roman Empire
and many since then had tried to unite
Europe by conquest most recently in
Napoleon and Hitler could Europe be
united peacefully and democratically
that was the problem faced by the
founding fathers of the movement for
European unity and they found the answer
by not confronting the issue directly
and here they differed from the founding
fathers if I were to say to you that the
9th of May 1950 was one of the most
important dates in post-war European
history and I suspect that most of you
would not know what I was talking about
the same would be true incidentally if I
said that to a British audience they
would not know what you were talking
about but the 9th of May was the date of
the Schumann Declaration which gave rise
to the first steps towards European
unity the European Coal and Steel
community created in 1952 and one
commentators said every decade that
passes confirms this events as one of
the landmarks of a century the
implications go well beyond Europe now
Robbie Schumann who was a foreign
minister of France the author of the
Declaration had been born in Luxembourg
but has spent much of his early life in
the border area of Lorraine which was
part of Germany until 1919 having been
conquered by Bismarck in his war against
France in 1870 shoe man had been
conscripted to fight for Germany in 1914
but had been rejected on health grounds
in the second world war he had been a
member of the French Resistance so he
had been a German citizen before
becoming a French citizen at the age of
32 he regarded himself as a
franco-german however he was not the
prime mover of the project that honor
belongs to Jean Monnet
a diplomat and international civil
servant a remarkable man never elected
to any public office or holding any post
in any national government he wielded
greater influence in
20th century than almost all elected
politicians he's regarded as the first
statesman of interdependence and as
early as 1954 sorry as early as 1943 he
said there will be no peace in Europe if
the states are reconstituted on the
basis of national sovereignty the
countries of Europe are too small to
guarantee their peoples and necessary
prosperity and Social Development and it
was Monet who wrote the Schumann
declaration it might well have been
called the Monet declaration the
movement for unity began with the
regulation of the production of coal and
steel under a supranational Authority
the European Coal and Steel community it
continued with the Treaty of Rome 1957
establishing the European communities
sometimes called the Common Market which
became a single community in 1967 and
then with the Treaty of Maastricht in
1992 establishing the European Union and
providing for a common European currency
in the euro and the Schumann plan was
intended as the answer to a practical
problem that of reintegrating West
Germany into the economic life of
Western Europe so as to ensure revival
and the problem was perhaps a bit easier
because Germany was not only defeated
but divided at that time and the plan
was based on a mixture of fear and hope
the fear that the recovery of German
industrial might would lead to war and
the hope that coal and steel could be
turned into weapons of peace to
undermine the basis of antagonism well
Edward Heath the Prime Minister took
Britain into the European Community in
1973 told the House of Commons in 1975
rightly that the purpose was political
he said the European community had been
founded for a political purpose it was
not a federal but a political purpose
the political purpose was to absorb the
new Germany into the structure of the
European family and economic means were
adopted for that
very political purpose economic means
for political purpose now this community
was devised during the period of the
Cold War when Europe was divided but the
movement to integrate Europe was not
intended to ratify the division on the
continent on the contrary the founding
fathers saw it as a step towards a
complete unification of Europe since the
United Germany firmly anchored in Europe
would be the best guarantee the Russians
could have that there will be no revival
of German aggression a Winston Churchill
who was a strong proponent of a united
Europe he'd be expelled I think from the
Conservative Party today for that reason
but he said at the Albert Hall in 1948
the whole purpose of a united democratic
Europe is to give definite guarantees
against aggression the creation of a
healthy and contented Europe is the
first and truest interest of a Soviet
Union we therefore hope that all sincere
efforts to promote European government
and stability would receive as they
deserve the sympathy and support of
Russia and speaking in Brussels in 1949
Churchill said with great presence the
Europe we seek to unite is all Europe
now the mechanism proposed for the Coal
and Steel community was that
the production of coal and steel in
France and Germany be placed under a
common Authority called the high
authority a transnational body whose
members were to be appointed by the
Member States but were not to represent
the Member States they were to represent
a common European interest which
transcended the interests of the
separate States they were to embody a
European perspective not a national
perspective and the purpose was to make
war not only unthinkable but materially
impossible because France and Germany
would be in an embrace so close that
neither could draw back far enough at it
the other
and this plan marked the birth of
European unity the Coal and Steel
community like the European Union had a
Council of Ministers a court of justice
and a common assembly a European
Parliament in embryo though that common
assembly was not directly elected but
appointed by the various national
parliaments and it had a new supervisory
powers the European partners much wider
powers the high authority was the
European Commission in embryo now since
1985 9th of May which I mentioned the
date of the Schumann plan have been
known on the continent as Europe day and
sometimes as Schumann day as apparently
moved by Catholics to beatify Schumann's
but it appears the Catholic Church
demands evidence of a miracle before
that can occur some might perhaps say
the creation of the European Coal and
Steel community just a few years after
the end of the war with all the
antagonists at aroused was such a
miracle others might say the continued
survival of the European Union is a
miracle
the Catholic Church is not yet convinced
now if as Schumann hoped this was to be
the basis of European unity then all
other three European countries were to
be invited to join and in the end the
founding nations were France Germany
Italy and the three Benelux countries
they were also the founding members of
the European communities who signed the
Treaty of Rome in 1957
Britain did not join and Britain did not
join the European communities until 1973
after two previous attempts to join had
been vetoed by the French president
Charles de Gaulle now after processions
you may say after brexit to the European
Union which is a successor to his
earlier but it will have 27 members and
almost every country in Europe will
belong the main exceptions are the
countries of the Western Balkans most of
which were part of the former Yugoslavia
now in his memoirs Dean Acheson the
United States Secretary of State from
1949 53 he calls his men was present at
the creation a good title because these
were the
formative steps are absolutely
fundamental they were the years in which
new relationships were being formed
which would long survive and until the
late 1950s that countries of Europe had
a great deal of freedom of maneuver
Britain particularly so own to the great
prestige she'd won during the war after
that relationships would have become
frozen and it was to prove very
difficult to alter them
one British ex ambassador to America
declared in 1954 that history has given
us a period within which to work out our
problems the period began with the end
of the Second World War and may last as
long as the working lifetime of my
generation that is perhaps a decade it
would not be longer it may well be
shorter the whole period whatever its
duration may be is crucial what we do or
fail to do will be decisive there will
be no second chance and that was right
the fact that Britain did not join until
fifteen years after the European
community was formed meant she had no
voice in the institutional structure nor
in the economic arrangements agreed on
by the founding members she had to
accept rules and institutions drawn up
by others it was a fatal handicap now
why did Britain not join at the time the
Declaration was made in 1950 Britain had
a Labour government which had just
nationalized the steel industry and so
just nationalized the toll industry and
was in the process of nationalizing the
steel industry how could these
nationalized industries be merged with a
European Authority built up on the basis
of private ownership the government
moreover was a firm believer in
Keynesian economics which entailed
national counter-cyclical economic
policies how could they cede authority
to a higher authority which could close
mines or steel works in Britain speaking
for the conservative opposition the
future Prime Minister Harold Macmillan
remembering very high levels of Arlen
employment in his constituency in the
north of England between the walls said
this one thing is certain and we may as
well face it now people are not going to
hand over to any footprint the right to
close down our pits or steel works we
will allow no supranational authority to
put large masses of our people out of
work in Durham in the Midlands in South
Wales or in Scotland and there was a
wider fear concerning the final
destination of the European movement a
federation Anthony Eden who became
Foreign Secretary in the Conservative
government in 1951 he spoke at Columbia
University in January 1952 when he got
an honorary degree at the time when the
Americans were trying to press Britain
to join a united Europe to strengthen
defense and and Western Europe of the
whole and he said this if you drive a
nation to adopt procedures which run
counter to its instincts you weaken and
may destroy the motive force of its
action you will realize that I'm
speaking of the frequent suggestions
that the United Kingdom should join a
federation on the continent of Europe
and he concluded this is something which
we know in our bones we cannot do now
even his period of prime ministers
obscured effect he was a very great
Foreign Secretary he used the phrase in
our bones British resistance to joining
a European Federation was not something
that could be overcome by argument by a
calculation of costs and benefits it was
an instinctive hostility something we in
our bones knew we could never join
this was a crucial turning point in
European history until then it had been
assumed that Britain had a veto on
European integration and an American
diplomat serving in London David Bruce
who later became ambassador said this in
1950 he said there will be no European
integration without wholehearted
participation by the United Kingdom then
he said the second proposition the
united kingdom will not wholeheartedly
participate
so the third proposition was ago
there will be no purely European
integration and that assessment was
shared by British officials one of whom
made the arrogant comment in 1948 if the
United Kingdom's not lead the movement
it will not occur for no other country
in Europe has the moral authority and
the organising capacity now the success
of the Coal and Steel community showed
the Europeans they could build a united
Europe without Britain Britain was not
as it were present at the creation
Robert Schuman when he produced the plan
he said the nations of Europe shared a
common destiny and Britain has always
been ambivalent about whether she shares
that destiny or not and that ambivalence
is well exemplified in the career of the
greatest of British twentieth-century
statesmen Winston Churchill we've been a
strong supporter of the United Europe
but could not quite make up his mind as
to whether Britain herself could be part
of it
now in the postwar years
Churchill's involvement in the European
cause came about in a curious way he had
been defeated in the general election of
1945 and just over a year after the end
of the war in September 1946 he was due
to make a speech at Zurich University
and he was apparently in of a grumpy
mood before the speech and his
son-in-law Duncan sands who were also
Conservative MPs asked him why he was so
grumpy and Churchill said he was due to
make a speech comparing the British
parliamentary system
and the Swiss cantonal system of
government and San said you know nothing
about that
and Churchill so that is why I'm so
irritable sans suggested instead of a
speech on comparative government
Churchill should instead speak on the
question they had been discussing that
very night at dinner the future of
Europe and that was how the Zurich
speech came to be born and Churchill
said when the Nazi power was broken I
asked myself what was the best advice I
could give my fellow citizens in our
ravaged and exhausted continent is my
counsel to Europe can be given in a
single word
unite their walls he said a remedy which
if it were generally and spontaneously
adopted would as if by a miracle
transform the whole scene and would in a
few years make all Europe all the
greater part of it as free and happy as
Switzerland is today and he then said I
am going to say something that will
astonish you the first step in the
recreation of the European family must
be a partnership between France and
Germany there can be no revival of
Europe without a spiritually great
France and a spiritually great Germany
and that was said just 16 months after
the defeat of Nazi Germany there's
wasn't the first occasion by any means
on which she'd argued for united Europe
he'd first argued for it in 1930 and
then in 1942 after the Battle of El
Alamein when it was clear that Britain
would win the war he wrote his foreign
secretary in 1942 he wrote to Anthony
Eden with his views on the post-war
world he said I must admit that thoughts
rest primarily in Europe the revival of
the glory of Europe hard as it is to say
now I look forward to a United States of
Europe in which the barriers between the
nations would be greatly minimized and
unrestricted travel will be possible in
his Zurich speech
Churchill said Britain must be among the
friends and sponsors of the new Europe
he didn't say Britain should be part of
it
but in other speeches at the time he did
say that Britain should be a part of it
but his own Conservative government
elected in 1951 adopted the same policy
as the Labour government of detachment
from Europe and when in 1961 Harold
Macmillan applied to join the European
community Churchill very rarely for him
couldn't make up his mind whether he was
in favor or not he wrote the following
letter to the chair of his constituency
party he said for many years I had
believed that measures to promote
European unity were ultimately essential
to the well-being of the West in a
speech at Zurich in 1946 I urged the
creation of the European family and I'm
sometimes given credit for stimulating
the ideals of European unity which led
to the formation of the economic and the
other to communities in the aftermath of
the Second World War the key to these
endeavors lay in partnership between
France and Germany at that time this
happy outcome seemed a fantasy but it is
now accomplished and France and West
Germany are more intimately linked that
may have ever been before in their
history they together with Italy Belgium
Holland and Luxembourg are welding
themselves into an organic whole
stronger and more dynamic from the sum
of its parts we might well play a great
part in these developments to the profit
not only of ourselves but of our
European friends also but we have
another role which we cannot abdicate
that of leader of the British
Commonwealth in my conception of a
united Europe I never contemplated the
dilution of the Commonwealth to sum up
my views I would say this I think that
the governments are right to apply to
join the European communities not
because I am yet convinced that we shall
be able to join but because there
appears to be no other way by which we
can find out exactly whether the
conditions of men
Jabar acceptable now I think it'd be
fair to say that this is a fence fitting
letter he couldn't the great man simply
couldn't make up his mind
but after two goals veto in 1963
Churchill draft a letter to the Belgian
statesman poor re-spark saying the
future of Europe if Britain were to be
excluded is bleak indeed but in the end
he didn't send a letter and the key
question is what would have been his
attitude when he came to realise the
Commonwealth whatever its value could
not be a substitute for Empire in other
words was not a political unit and
Edward Heath who was a colleague in his
peacetime government later wrote that
Churchill's reluctance was based on
circumstance it was not opposition based
on principles and that when Churchill
had realized that Britain would not
remain an imperial power he would like
de Gaulle in France have perceived his
country's future lay in Europe I myself
take that view but of course the
argument is still open was a big
argument in Britain
perhaps a futile one on what Churchill
would have done how he devoted from the
referendum and so on now you may think
all this is odd because Britain after
all is geographically part of Europe
though many in Britain are accustomed to
speak of Europe when they mean the
continent and recently British ministers
have taken to saying that when we leave
the European Union we won't be leaving
Europe as if we could as it were leave
Europe but we've never been able to give
a definitive answer to the question of
whether politically we belong or not and
I think to most Americans this attitude
may seem borrowed after all Dover is 27
miles from Calais on a clear day you can
see the French coast from Dover and the
Channel Tunnel opened in 1994 links
Brittany more closely to the continent
you may say we no longer in Ireland even
perhaps Europe looks more united from
America than it does to Europeans
themselves the British store and AJP
Taylor once said on that issue no doubt
all the inhabitants of the world look
the same when viewed from the moon
all sheep look alike to us and probably
we all look alike to sheep but Britain
is different and the reasons lie deep in
British history and the nature of
Britain's imperial past because too many
in the 20th century Britain appeared a
different power from those on the
continent at the beginning of the 20th
century Westminster was the Parliament
not only the United Kingdom but also the
Empire Westminster was then often known
as the Imperial Parliament and that term
survived a remarkably long time it was
last used in the 1970s by a Labour Prime
Minister Harold Wilson in debates on
devolution he spoke Westminster as the
Imperial Parliament it was a legislature
of the largest land Empire the world had
ever seen covering in addition to 38
million people living in Britain around
three hundred and sixty million people
around the world covering one-fifth of
the globe and therefore the political
answer to whether Britain was part of
Europe was not as clear of the
geographical answer and if you go back
to 1900 most people would have said the
less Britain had to do with the
continent the better we were an imperial
power and not a European power in 1938
when it seemed that Britain might have
to go to war because of the conflict
between Germany and Czechoslovakia over
the fate of the german-speaking
inhabitants of Czechoslovakia Neville
Chamberlain the Prime Minister broadcast
the country saying this how horrible
fantastic incredible it is that we
should be digging trenches and trying on
gas masks because of a quarrel in a
faraway country between people of which
we know nothing and he's been much
criticized for this statement it
probably did reflect the feelings of
many people in Britain and a year later
we were to go to war because of the
quarrel in another faraway country
Poland but the British people would not
have regarded Canada Australia or New
Zealand which are far further away in in
geographical terms as faraway countries
these were countries in
which many people had relatives and
again to quote Anthony Eden in 1952 he
told his private sector what you've got
to remember if you looked at the postbag
of any English village and examined the
letters coming in from abroad to the
whole population ninety percent of them
would come from way beyond Europe now
because of her island situation her
trading position was quite different
from that of the continental powers as
the first industrial nation
she had a much smaller agricultural
sector than her continental competitors
and as a maritime power she relied on
cheap food from the colonies her
commercial system was based on free
trade unlike the high tariffs countries
of the continent with their large
agricultural sectors and because she was
a maritime power and an island she could
rely on the Navy to defend her unlike
continental countries she did not need a
large army and she did not have
conscription in peacetime until April
1939 just five months before the
outbreak of the second war in 1900
Britain had no troops on the continent
at all and she'd not agreed to maintain
troops on the continent until 1954 we
hadn't at that time before the First
World War no European alliances until
young science except with Portugal we
lived in splendid isolation protected by
the Navy and the Empire you may remember
the words of John of Gaunt in
Shakespeare's Richard a second this
fortress built by nature for herself
against infection and the hand of war
the infection presumably comes from the
continent so Britain had a policy
defined by Disraeli as one of reserve
but proud reserve now that period of
isolation no it's long gone still
retains some of its impact upon the
British people and that was what
president de Gaulle of France said when
he first vetoed the British application
to join the European community in 1963
he said that the Treaty of Rome which
established the European communities had
been signed in 1957
by six continental states which were of
the same nature Britain by contrast was
insula she is maritime she is linked
through her exchanges her markets her
supply lines to the most diverse and
often the most distant countries she
pursues essentially industrial and
commercial activities and only slight
agricultural ones so the goal said the
nature of the structure the very
situation that our England's differ
profoundly from those of the
Continentals but could Britain change
could she become European world a goal
successor George Pompidou certainly
thought so and in 1971 Edward Heath came
to visit him to successfully negotiate
Britain's entry and Pompidou gave a
press conference in which he said this
he said he'd asked Edward Heath what he
thought of Europe in other words whether
Britain was really determined to become
European were the Britain which is which
is an island was determined to tie
herself to the continent and whether she
was prepared consequently to loosen her
ties with the open sea towards which she
has always looked and Pompidou
summarized Heath's response and I can
say he said that the explanations and
views expressed to me by mr. Heath are
in keeping with France's concept of the
future of Europe but were they in
correspondence with the concept of the
British people towards Europe this is
not at all clear now of course the 20th
century Chone Britain could not isolate
herself from the continent she thought
many wars because of Europe but
nevertheless in history the main events
which have defined British consciousness
are events that occurred when Britain
was alone confronting a hostile
continent under Napoleon and of course
Hitler and that's why Dunkirk is seen in
Britain not as a kind of defeat but
something the victory
and this well summed up by the king at
the time George of Sixth who wrote his
mother perhaps not appreciating the
danger Britain was in personally I feel
happier now that we have no allies to be
polite to and to pamper and the King's
official biographer says and in these
sentiments he was at one with the vast
majority of his subjects and 1940 showed
that Britain didn't stand or fall in the
same way as the countries of the
continent when France was defeated she
was defeated when Britain was defeated
she could withdraw from the continent
and because she was an island could
carry on the fight so her fate was not
bound up with that of the continent the
same of course is true a Russia for a
very different reason of the vast
Eurasian landmass and of course that war
emphasized the differences between
Britain and the continent Britain was
the only one of the European combatants
which had been ruled neither bound
fascist or Nazi government nor invaded
by the Nazi or fascist powers in
consequence she was the only country
whose institutions remained intact
during the war most of them had to adopt
new constitutions and to come to terms
with the experience of fascism Nazism or
collaboration to put the point somewhat
crudely young people on the continent
had to ask themselves whether they could
be proud of what their parents or
grandparents might have done in the war
people in Britain didn't have to ask
that question and run Bulgarian
political scientists have said being
European is about being aware of what we
did and so you they needed to overcome
the past by creating new institutions in
their own countries and a new
transnational nationalism the sense of
being European was a state of mind born
of defeat occupation and the gulf
between those who collaborated and those
who resisted now Britain through the
accident of geography did not share
those feelings and they saw themselves
still as a great power and the same
British ex ambassador to the United
States
I've already quoted said in 1954 what is
note were
as a way we take this axiom that Britain
is a great power for granted it is not a
belief arrived at after reflection by a
conscious decision it is part of the
habit and furniture of our minds a
principle so much at one with our
outlook and character that it determines
the way we act without emerging into
clear consciousness but it was not taken
for granted of course abroad when the
facts of the loss of empire and
Britain's economic weakness were
painfully apparent so there was this
huge difference in national psychology
and the psychology of self-confidence
was wet expressed by the labor postwar
prime minister clement attlee in Molalla
last if not the last speeches he ever
made in 1967 to a labor committee called
the Common Market safeguards committee
which is a euphemism for Britain not
joining Europe and I should say that
Ashley was a very laconic and terse
speaker who never wasted words and he
said this his speech was very short and
laconic he said the Common Market the
so-called Common Market of Six Nations
know them all well very recently this
country spent a great deal of blood and
treasure rescuing four of them from the
other two and then he sat down and ROM
money wisely said Britain had not been
conquered or invaded she felt no need to
exercise history that point of view her
commitment to the content was bound to
be limited so perhaps the goal was right
and Pompidou was wrong it was not that
we were not a cooperative power in
Europe we were perfectly happy to
cooperate as long as that did not
involve any commitment to a
supranational organisation that was the
key worry that we had and and which is
still where
now if Churchill was I think one of
those who did understand that the war
had undermined Britain's international
position he saw it as essentially a
temporary phenomenon something that
could be transformed through an act of
will as he had transformed Britain's
position in 1940 through a similar act
of will I think he did not appreciate
the war had permanently undermine
Britain's international position so that
she was never going to be a great power
again when he became leader of the
Conservative Party in 1940 some months
RT became prime minister he said one of
the central purposes of his political
career had been the maintenance of the
enduring greatness of Britain and her
Empire the central theme of his
political career was the decline of
British power perhaps inevitable but it
was declined and Churchill understood it
he told his private secretary in
retirement that he'd been a failure and
his private secretary thought he was
gaga he said why do so and Churchill
said I worked very hard all my life and
I've achieved a great deal in the end to
achieve nothing and that last word
according to his private secretary fell
with sombre emphasis he said to a
political colleague towards the end of
his life his torrents are apt to judge
ministers less by the victories achieved
under their direction than by the
political results which followed from
them judged by that standard I am Not
sure that I shall be held to have done
very well
now in 1949 robert schumann had said
without britain there can be no europe
but the success of the Coal and Steel
community showed that without Britain
there could be Europe and it showed that
Britain would not be a dominant power in
the new Europe all this was confirmed in
1956 by the suez crisis which led to a
further divergence between British and
French policy for Britain the failure of
the Suez expedition brought the lesson
that Britain needed to regenerate the
special relationship with the United
States the French drew a different
lesson Germany's Chancellor Konrad
Adenauer told the French Foreign
Minister Christian Beno on the 6th of
November 1956 just after the failure of
the expedition was clear but for Britain
France and Germany there was only one
way of playing a decisive role in the
world that is to unite Europe we have no
time to waste
make Europe your revenge and that is
what the French did but not written and
Adenauer said that Britain had become
like a rich man who had lost all his
property but does not realize it and
perhaps worth mentioning the founders of
European unity were not only Jean Monnet
and Joseph Stalin but also Egypt's
leader President Nasser indeed a French
observer once said a statue should be
raised to Egyptian leader Gamal Abdel
Nasser as the Federation of Europe for
nationalizing the canal and creating the
conditions for the largest Western
European powers to bond now let me
conclude in the following way you can
have two alternative conclusions you can
first say it was a mistake for Britain
to have lost the leadership of Europe
American Secretary of State Dean Acheson
said it was the greatest mistake of the
post-war period but you can also say it
was a right to
because if Britain had joined she would
have faced the same sorts of problems
that she actually did face after she did
join in 1973 who Euroskeptics would say
for Britain it was the commitment to
Europe not the refusal it was a mistake
though this view has to confront the
fact that since 1961 every British Prime
Minister has thought it would be best
for Britain to be part of the European
community of the European Union but when
the Treaty of Rome was signed in 1957
hardly anyone suggested to Britain that
she should join and in particular those
who were late to advocate British
membership were opposed to it Harold
Macmillan for example who was later to
lead the government which made the
application said I do not believe this
house would ever agreed to our entering
arrangements which as a matter of
principle would prevent our treating the
great range of imports from the
Commonwealth at least as favorably as
those from the European countries so
this objection even if there were no
other would be quite fatal to any
proposal that the United Kingdom should
seek to take part in a European Common
Market by joining a customs union in the
1959 election the first art of the
formation of the European communities
none of the party manifesto suggested
that Britain should join not even the
small liberal party which was to become
the most enthusiastically pro-european
of all the British parties its election
manifesto did not mention Europe and by
contrast with a long and somewhat
tortured discussion of the Schumann plan
in Britain membership of the European
community was hardly discussed at all it
was taken for granted that Britain
should not join the decision was taken
by default because it was a
reaffirmation of existing policy to join
would have implied a radical
discontinuity of approach an imaginative
leap and leap of faith perhaps in 1954
the former version Baz drive twice
quoted said this we thought that the old
Europe of independent quarreling
sovereign states was continuing it was
not something novel was happening and
perhaps British leaders were at fault
in not recognizing it the British would
remain good Europeans in the sense of
being in Europe and being committed to
European security but not in the sense
of being of Europe and the British
attitude has not in my view
fundamentally altered since these
formative years she has not been
uncertain half in half Alton generally
opposed the further integration but
unable to suggest any alternative
commanding confidence on the continent
the pattern was set for better or worse
in the 1950s moves on the continent
towards European unity was seen as a
problem not as a challenge much less an
inspiration
and how British politicians sought to
resolve that problem will be the subject
of my next lecture but it may be that
all the arguments were here today with
first rehearsed in the 1950s and there
is nothing new to say but nevertheless I
do hope to find some material for the
remaining three lecture sir thank you
a little conversation and to get us
started
it's a word that I'm not sure I heard
you say in the entirety of your remarks
but at least to my mind it hovered over
much of your discussion especially the
second half so we heard about France
Germany even Switzerland Egypt you
didn't hear the word India but of course
when you talk about Empire see here's
the problem you know for these guys they
think of Churchill's he's up there with
Franklin Roosevelt and Vado's you see
against Hitler and against Mussolini
Stalin is a little bit more complicated
but he's the one who sees Stalin as the
problem before Americans turn against
Uncle Joe but Americans you know what
they think it's boring stuff thinking
close your eyes and thinking when I say
Churchill you think Hitler Roosevelt
Stalin you do not think on you and if
you think Gandhi you see then you
actually understand that Churchill is
actually why the big losers the loss of
this jewel in the crown
the Empire this way have very
far-reaching consequences for British
self-understanding and for Hitler's
obviously for Churchill's own that was a
Freudian slip he's skinny because I feel
my dad was born under the British Raj
and millions of Americans to be millions
inference of Indians died in famines
because the Brits did not actually do so
well by the Indian perspective the
massacre in Ritzer and and these massive
M's Churchill has a lot to answer for
to Indians and so I'd like you to say a
little bit more about that because it
hovered over India that you've implied
was absolutely central to the British
Empire and it was governed from
Westminster until the time of Indian
independence and it conditioned
Britain's whole world policy in the 19th
and early 20th century because the
defense of India was important to
Britain as the defense of Britain and
therefore we had all sorts of trading
bases on the route to India we needed to
protect the Suez Canal at the Cape and
so on and trading bases between India
and Australia to link the Empire and
British elites said this is of
fundamental importance to us and as soon
as we lose India imperialist said we
will cease to be a great power and
Churchill who was imperialist certainly
took that view and I think it's probably
fair to say that India is one of the few
countries perhaps the only country where
Churchill is not regarded as a hero for
the reasons you have given it is fair to
say he was the strongest in condemnation
again it's a massacre in the House of
Commons he and announced that absolutely
but he was he was against independent
Indian independence and he fought indeed
against even moderate air engine
self-government for reasons which I
think are worth looking
that he said India at the time was
divided that one-third of India was
governed by the Indian princes who were
as it were subordinate to British rule
but broadly autonomous in their domestic
policies and Churchill thought it would
be very difficult to get the Indian
princes to accept a united India this
was done through the doings of Lord
Mountbatten the last Viceroy who
Churchill fell out with for this very
reason he also said that British rule is
the only thing that keeps the different
religions of India particular Muslims
and Hindus together and that has not
proved a wholly false prediction because
with Indian independence Burma was not
strictly adding part of India but
Pakistan and Bangladesh are now
independent countries and facing great
difficulties and unlike India they are
countries governed by a particular
religion I mean India is a secular
country and liberal country a great
liberal democracy Pakistan and
Bangladesh really are not and Churchill
took the view be better if the whole
Indian Empire held together and of
course when Indian independence came
there were massacres on both sides with
Hindus in what is now Pakistan being
slaughtered and expelled and Muslims in
India the same happened to them I think
many people don't understand how little
the British public were interested in
Empire just as perhaps have a little
interested in Europe it's a matter for
the elites who wanted Britain to be a
great power in the world and to be
represented at the top table most people
in Britain had much more mundane things
to get on with in their lives to give
one extreme example in 1950 a survey was
done but asked the British people if
they could name a single British colony
49% could not one person gave the answer
Lincolnshire and the Empire and this was
why we managed to
get rid of the Empire without the
traumas that affected say France or
Portugal or Belgium most British people
weren't interested just as they're not
on the whole very interested in Europe
they're interested in in British Affairs
what goes on in Britain the problems
they have domestically the health
service the economy had transferred all
the rest of it and you get a I think a
false view of Britain by looking at
Churchill and Churchill himself
recognized that he said sadly to a
colleague at the end of his life you
know I could have defended the British
Empire against the British
well I should say to declare my
credential in the beginning that I was
in the losing side in the referendum
that I voted remain and perhaps the
implications of what I said was that
Britain should have been there but I
really think that the differences in
structure and perception between Britain
and the Commonwealth country sorry and
the European country the Continental
countries are such and the difference in
the history that we'd have faced the
same problems if we had been there at
the beginning we rather think perhaps
our prestige would have helped us and it
might have done for a while but our
outlook as' was so different in my
opinion just as I hold a view which is
incapable of conformational refutation
but even if we hadn't had that
referendum in 2016 was the strains and
the relationship would probably have led
to us leaving eventually anyway
and this really entrenches on something
I'm going to say next time but the
reason we joined was not we shared a
belief in that common destiny but we saw
a various economic benefits for
ourselves in joining or at least
stopping disadvantages so we weren't
part of it and I think that would have
always been the case and that that's a
judgment of seeing capable of any
confirmation or refutation in it the
general view in Britain I suppose
amongst the liberal elite is we made a
mistake but I think the argument isn't
perhaps as clear-cut as I presented it
it's true we were begged to join begged
to give the leadership of Europe and one
can see why wasn't done we and after all
one has perhaps I've underestimated that
democracy in Europe will seem very
unstable at the time France had a new
government every nine months under the
Fourth Republic a very large Communist
Party calmness reposed to this so were
the go lists at that time German
democracy was a new thing no one could
believe it necessary flourish so was
Italian democracy these seemed unstable
countries was we had do you see what we
called the old Commonwealth Australia
Canada New Zealand we thought how ties
were there and we thought perhaps
foolishly we were taken more seriously
in America than
so attending that was the key I think it
was the particular Commonwealth links
and the links with America where as
remember his mother was American and
someone once said of church of limas
half American but all British and no I
think he wasn't thinking I think it it
would have been a view without any
really conscious thought if we join
Europe we abound to dominate I think he
would have I mean I think most not just
him but I think everyone in Britain
would have thought that at the end of
the 1940s and it his his some his
ambivalence was simply whether it was
compatible with the Commonwealth ties or
the as he used to call it the Empire
didn't like the term Commonwealth a map
she preferred term Empire so I I think
was that but I say he was he had a
tremendous insight from from 1930 really
onwards that Europe had to unite he was
a in a way the profit of united Europe
but he was ambivalent couldn't make him
up his mind whether Britain should
actually join I say it would he through
knew him well so that his opposition was
a matter of circumstance well you may
say Heath would have said that his
grandson in in the House of Commons
Nicholas Soames former Tory Minister
more strong pro-european though another
grandson now
was not so it's impossible to say I I
would put this younger and in two points
first you're right the 1975 referendum
the first we had on that when we were
already in Europe led to a two-to-one
majority for remaining in this trenches
on what I'm going to say in a future
lecture but habit of it now in my
opinion this did not show great
enthusiasm for European unity but fear
of what would happen if we left because
in the 70s we were the sick man of
Europe in a way that I think perhaps
France is now inflation was twenty six
percent unemployment heavily rising the
trade unions seemed to have a
stranglehold on British life and
Churchill's son-in-law who'd been a
European commissioner said this was no
time for Britain to leave a Christmas
club let alone the Common Market we were
in a very weak position I think was fear
of the consequence of not going and at
that time also the issue was presented
as one of moderates against extremists
because the people who were against were
the extreme left and extreme right whom
people didn't like and everyone of
moderate views therefore was Pro Europe
now in the 2016 referendum that wasn't
the case we had no fear of leaving
because we seem to be doing better than
the eurozone countries we seem to be
were doing rather well and we had no no
inflation unemployment was falling and
the trade union power had been much
weakened and there were many people on a
moderate side of politics who did favor
leaving Europe it wasn't simply
moderates
versus extremists in in 1975 one of the
Pro Europeans had said that if we leave
Europe we'll be in an old people's home
for fading nations and he said it
wouldn't be a very comfortable old
people's home I don't like the look of
some of the wardens now you may say
that's true now of the wardens who are
there but I mean there's two facts that
I think um if I may say so I think you
overestimate him the press I no scholar
of the press we've seen with the
newspaper editors want to sell papers
and they sell papers by reflecting
popular opinion rather than creating it
to give you one example there was a
large discussion a long discussion in
the conservative part in 2008 when the
lisbon treaty was signed on whether
there should be a referendum on it and
the key populist paper The Daily Mail
had nothing in its headlines about
didn't run the issue it realized people
weren't interested at that time and so I
think the pay at the newspapers only had
effect because they reflected opinion
that was already there not because they
created the pin knowing that wasn't the
reason for the results a reason for the
resulting basically [ __ ] didn't want to
be part of a European call it quasi
Federation whatever you call they didn't
want to be part of it
restitute here your body of work has
focused quite a lot on many other things
the question of referendum indirect
minimum receive Newcomb was it
imaginable to a referendum on British
and treatment earlier or it's a great
concept of British referendum later
Linda Susan beginning on entering or
rather than whether they should leave
and satisfy yes my and then finally
connected because you compare to the
American Constitution if the other
countries in Europe have entered the
common market or the EU in more of an
American referendum way yeah
we're ever and main.c point the other
countries I think would all have
accepted it because for them it was an
escape from a condition they didn't like
for the six as I said that escaped from
the dilemmas and traumas of the war
occupation resistance collaboration all
the rest of it for most of the other
countries an escape from dictatorship
Spain Portugal Greece the ex communist
countries pwned Hungary Romania Bulgaria
the rest so I think they would all have
joined Denmark had a referendum and
Sweden had a referendum I think they
joined Ireland had a referendum a can
interesting point about whether Britain
should have had one and this was
discussed and Edward Heath said well
we're represented by the Parliament we
won't have one I think if we had had one
I think you're probably right we
wouldn't enjoy in the opinion polls may
show that and the referendum was until
we had one thought to be
unconstitutional but then in Britain
what is unconstitutional mean and it was
a hell the Labour Party which succeeded
Heath in 1974 had a referendum not
because it sincerely wished to and to
learn about the views of the British
people nothing as grand as that but to
cover over a party dispute and the the
left-wing then was against and the
right-wing broadly in favor and that
threatened to break the party up so
Wilson said let's have a referendum and
then bow
parties can support the labor government
on the grounds of the people will decide
and Wilson having said six out of seven
conservative Prime's have been ruined by
Europe Harold Wilson whose reputation
isn't high in Britain probably is the
only Prime Minister to have triumphed
over Europe and the day after the
referendum yielded that two-to-one
majority he said to his private
secretary and people say I have no sense
of strategy that I can't think
strategically he said I think there's
anyone who succeeded but our problem now
which I want to talk about further in
later lectures is that for the first
time in British history the referendum
has yielded a result which Parliament
does not like so it poses a sovereignty
of the people against the sovereignty of
parliament and this is one of the
reasons for our problems in implementing
brexit never happened before in British
history and people who are against
referendums of which there are a larger
number perhaps they ally themselves with
some reactionary points of view but one
great French reactionary Joseph de
Maistre who was opposed to French
Revolution so the principle of the
sovereignty of the people is so
dangerous that even if it were true
it would be best to conceal it and that
is what many people feel in Britain now
[Applause]
[Music]